earlier this year smile introduced the
world to a curse that seems unbeatable a
demon that passes on through trauma and
concrete hallucinations that are so real
he begin to question literally
everything around you so what do you do
when your senses start to be used as
Weapons against you you turn to this
episode that's why I have a solution
here's how you beat the unbeatable demon
of smile
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows exactly how to turn
that frown upside down how I clicking
the Subscribe button see doesn't it make
you feel a little bit better well at the
very least it made me feel better today
we're talking about smile the 2022
horror film that was an absolutely
massive hit critics loved it audiences
loved it and the accountants really
loved it you know because it made 216
million dollars off a 17 million dollar
budget not too shabby one reason for
that massive success the curse that
drives the action forward is unbeatable
you see the story follows Dr Rose Cotter
a psychiatrist who's traumatized after
witnessing one of her patients slice off
her face while wearing a big old creepy
grin that alone would be horrible enough
but things get way worse once Rose
starts seeing people with that same
creepy smile all around her
eventually she realized that she's been
cursed by this evil entity that isn't
really given a name in the movie it's
not even clear what this thing's
supposed to be ghost monster demon some
clear so I'm just gonna keep it as like
curse slash demon for now regardless the
curse starts giving Rose Vivid and
terrifying hallucinations which causes
her to push away from all her loved ones
eventually she learns that the curse is
passing along through trauma and that
the only way to get rid of it is to pass
it along by causing someone else trauma
otherwise you're just stuck waiting for
it to eventually claim your life a
ticking clock that the movie tells us
maxes out at around four days none of
them survived longer than a week some of
them didn't even
can past four days it's a terrifying
premise that makes for a fantastic film
but you all know me at this point loyal
theorists not just gonna sit back and
let the jump scares wash over me as I
munch my popcorn and drink out of my
gallon-sized jug of Diet Coke while I
was in the theater my theorist cogs
started to turn wondering what Rose or
anyone infected with this thing could do
to beat it surely there's gotta be a
strategy here that we can work out to
either break the smell Demon's curse or
just play into its rules in a way that
makes everyone happy in the end so I
looked online to see if anyone had one
and uh no actually not not really no one
came up with anything or let me correct
myself no one came up with anything that
kept us alive and also didn't kill a
bunch of other people so today I wanted
to see if we could possibly beat this
unbeatable challenge is it possible to
create a strategy that'll put a smile on
everyone's face and not in the creepy
cursed way strap in friends we're about
to find out let's start with the most
suggested method and the one that we
actually see Rose try in the movie
complete isolation you can't pass on the
demon through trauma if there's no one
to pass it on to you right well it might
work in theory in horror movie Theory
way too many syllables but in practice
no
no not so much isolating yourself
completely is something that's way
easier said than done in the movie we
watch as Rose tries to isolate herself
and her mother's abandoned house I don't
think you should be alone right now I
need to be alone
well there she confronts the childhood
trauma that's haunted her throughout her
entire life she processes it and she
basically defeats the demon isolation
for the win am I right wrong what at
first seemed like a victory for Rose was
actually just an incredibly elaborate
hallucination Rose never beat the smile
demon in fact she lured the Demon's next
victim to this isolated area and then
passed it along to him but okay what if
Rose were stronger or she was able to
see through the hallucinations could it
have worked in that case well no again
assuming you're not a billionaire you're
gonna need to go to work to pay for
stuff and while you could work from home
you gotta have something to eat which
means getting everything delivered to
your door AKA delivery people or it
means going to the grocery store AKA
being surrounded by some of the most
aggressive people on the planet okay so
I suppose you could do it if you were
able to avoid the hallucinations and you
work from home and had everything
delivered by a remote drone but even
then even if those huge conditions were
all in place there's still a massive
problem with this solution this plan has
to be permanent there would be no breaks
to your isolation every day for the rest
of your life would be spent alone
without anyone or anything to talk to
other than the demon tormenting you and
even without the supernatural element
here social isolation to this degree
would be really bad for your brain
Studies have shown that socially
isolated people are more likely to
suffer cognitive decline memory loss
dementia impaired concentration
depression anxiety all in all the
isolation strategy requires an insane
number of difficult qualifiers to work
perfectly and would still ultimately
lead you to a hard life full of mental
anguish forever alone in the end it
wouldn't necessarily classify that as
beating the smile curse so let's keep
looking shall we one other solution I
saw proposed by the channel wolfman's
got nards incredible channel name by the
way was based on the idea of controlling
who you pass your trauma on to remember
there's more than one way to pass on the
smile demon to the next victim if you
brutally kill someone in front of
another person the trauma of seeing that
passes the curse onto the witness this
is what the character Robert Talley did
in the movie to escape the smile demon
himself a man May Escape that Chain by
killing his neighbor and passing it to
his neighbor's wife you're patient
is going to die unless she kills someone
that's the only way you can get rid of
it and it worked the demon passed on and
never came back there's just one teeny
tiny itsy bitsy problem with that Robert
Talley is now in prison also he killed
someone that's not a great look but you
know for now we're just gonna focus on
the prison part what the wolfman's nard
suggested was exploiting this loophole
in a systematic way taking you your
curse and two of your closest most
Expendable friends to a remote location
step one rudely off the first of your
two travelmates that should pass the
curse on to your second friend who's
probably like whoa this was not the
desert party that I was expecting which
leads us to step number two bump that
one off as well the curse dies with him
and so does the only witness to your
crime I gotta say not only does the
Wolfman have nards it's also got himself
a pretty solid solution here assuming
you're thorough and cleaning up and
leaving no Tracy or crime you should be
in the clear and the demon is defeated
once and for all you survived you don't
have to live a life in isolation and
you're not in prison technically you've
completed the assignment there's just
you know two little problems there the
dead bodies that you left in your wake
sure you found a solution but was it the
best solution it's kind of like beating
a video game without getting all the
achievements is there a true ending here
is there a way to do a pacifist run
survive stay out of prison and kill zero
people we gotta at least try right okay
so what else do we know about this curse
well the smile demon doesn't seem to be
able to manifest itself in any physical
way anytime we see it manipulate
something in the real world it's quickly
revealed to be a hallucination happening
Inside the Mind of the current victim
for example here while taking the form
of rose's sister Holly it knocks on the
car window but it isn't actually there
or here when it makes Rose believe that
she's gotten a call from her home
security company but the phone
disappears from her hand when a real
call comes through at first the solution
here seems like it should be to set up
totems kind of like an Inception things
that can help you realize what is and
isn't real in that movie the main
character used a spinning top to
determine if he was in a dream or not so
could we potentially set up something
like this to help with rose well no
probably not like I just said we see
that the smile demons able to completely
hijack someone's senses to create
incredibly realistic fantasies it's even
able to completely change Rose's
perception of the gift that she's
preparing for her nephew though she
thinks she's wrapping up a toy train
it's actually a dead cat the smile
Demon's able to make her think her
bloody and furry cat is a toy train I
doubt that there would be any way to
find an item sound or visual cue that
would ground Rose back to reality Rose's
senses are always going to betray her
the hallucinations are just too strong
so what if we could just remove the
hallucinations that then would largely
remove the curse's power as its only
mode of attack is by mentally breaking
you down like I said before it doesn't
have physical power it only has mental
power there's just one problem
hallucinations are incredibly complex
and still poorly understood by science
the current working theory is that
they're based on the brain failing to
properly select which stimuli to focus
on and which to ignore for instance an
auditory hallucination which are the
most common types they might be caused
by the brain doing a bit of self-talk
but then accidentally thinking that
those words were said aloud and and what
makes hallucinations especially tricky
is that they're spread out across the
brain because they're actively tricking
your senses they activate all over the
brain depending on what type of
hallucination you're talking about
auditory hallucinations are associated
with activation of the middle and
Superior temporal cortex areas involved
in processing speech somatic
hallucinations basically Phantom
Sensations inside your body those are
associated with the parts of the brain
that are usually processing the sense of
touch so really to fight the curses hold
over your brain you're gonna have to
fight on the battleground of your brain
and you're going to be fighting multiple
fronts all at the same time making
things even more complicated are the
neurotransmitters involved at this point
I'm sure you know that neurotransmitters
are the chemical Messengers in the brain
that allow nerve impulses to travel
between cells right the one you always
hear about is dopamine that's the reward
chemical you do something good or
rewarding and your brain suddenly gets
flooded with dopamine as a big old pat
on the back or pat on the cerebellum
hallucinations in your brain though
they're not as simple as that one-to-one
relationship researchers believe that
they involve no less than five separate
neurotransmitters and it's not like the
levels are too high or too low they
require levels to neither be too high
nor too low striking a tricky balance so
knowing all of this is there a way to
fight off the hallucinations in a
healthy responsible way yes if you look
at Rose's symptoms after she gets
infected by the curse her condition is
shockingly similar to the psychotic
disorder of schizophrenia which is
characterized first and foremost by
hallucinations in fact according to the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders or DSM for short
persistent Supernatural hallucinations
coupled with a significant disturbance
in work performance and interpersonal
functioning are some of the top criteria
for diagnosing someone with
schizophrenia and Rose in the movie is
basically speed running her way to that
very diagnosis fortunately this means
that help may be out there to treat the
symptoms that she's experiencing
antipsychotic medications like clozapine
are specifically prescribed to relieve
hallucinations for people suffering from
schizophrenia they can help calm down
and clear confusion in a person with
acute psychosis within a matter of days
or even hours exactly the sort of
treatment time that we need for a fast
acting hallucination based curse now
that is a huge win we're getting the
treatment we need to silence the
mechanisms that the curse is using to
attack us but pharmacological Solutions
aren't going to be enough here whether
you're talking about schizophrenia or
the smile curse you see individuals
suffering from extreme hallucinations
tend to be less likely to take their
medication this happens for multiple
reasons they may deny their illness they
may have paranoia about the medication
they might not think they need it
anymore and the numbers here are telling
depending on the report you read
anywhere between 37 and 74 percent of
patients will stop their medication
prematurely and that is going to greatly
increase the risk of relapse So to avoid
the risk Rose would also need to be
receiving some form of psychotherapy the
incidence of schizophrenia relapse among
patients receiving therapy compared to
those without is roughly 18 versus 60
that is a massive difference now to be
fair this isn't a full out solution the
demon won't be destroyed in her brain or
anything it'll just be silenced it won't
have a means of attacking anymore it's a
thing that'll need to be maintained
lived with rather than defeated which
honestly is pretty darn fitting for the
movie sure on paper Smiles about a
demonic curse that passes from person to
person fine but what it's really about
is mental health and cycles of trauma I
mean the literal premise is putting on a
fake smile when just under the surface
you're in mental anguish doesn't get
much more clear-cut than that all of the
other solutions that I talked about
today isolating yourself trying to hurt
others they're all unhealthy ways of
dealing with mental illness but asking
for help taking medication learning to
live with mental illness and Trauma
there are the obvious answers that so
many people sadly avoid because of how
much stigma comes attached to mental
health issues and while smile ends on a
negative note with these real world
situations don't have to Rose refused to
acknowledge what was happening to her
until it was much too late and when she
did turn to others to help no one around
her believed her let that be the lesson
today be open and willing to listen with
an open in mind when someone cries out
for help and don't always trust the
smile on the outside we can be seriously
hurting Inside by helping each other
then and only then can we truly defeat
the demon but hey that's just a theory a
film Theory and cut
and hey speaking of beating horror
movies if you want the definitive way to
defeat Michael Myers from the Halloween
franchise once and for all that video is
available on the left or if you'd prefer
learn how to defeat the Nightmare Demon
Freddy Krueger via the video on the
rights and if you like these sorts of
episodes make sure you click subscribe
because we pop into them every once in a
while and there's some of my faves see
you all next week